[Musica]
po
partiamo
Allora tantissimi anni fa 40 milioni di
anni fa era su una
pianeta stavo aspettando che mi
trasportano verso la terra perché
sindaco della mia ha detto devi andare
per terra che ti aspetta una famiglia
allora sono qui sono io un po' diverso
di oggi con la mia valigia ma non era
solo la valigia era qua dentro che era
altra parte di valigia ero pronto di
attirare per terra sono attirato
abbastanza bene in una famiglia che
aveva incluso anche la sorella papà
mamma e sorella e ho cominciato a
incontrare una
realtà Cioè non sapevo camminare più qua
camminavo perché era non sapevo
camminare non sapevo un cavolo per però
era
interessante a un certo punto perché non
abbiamo 4 ore di
tempo ho incontrato la carta e la matita
la mia madre mi ha dato che era molto
furba mi ha dato una carta vuota e una
matita e voleva vedere cosa
succederà è successo questo ho
cominciato a fotografare il mondo
intorno a me come un bambino e questo
era un punto molto particolare per me
perché mi ha semplificato e è fatto
complicata la vita nello stesso tempo
perché semplificato semplificato per la
mia decisione per quello che sarò il
futuro
complicato
perché la durata di questa cosa è
abbastanza
lunga e quindi ho deciso molto presto da
quando ero bambino di di quando
diventerò
adulto sarò bambino di
professione
Quindi vado
avan sono io tutto
elettrato ho cominciato a giocare
e ho trovato la strada ho cominciato a
curiosare la vita è partita e ho
cominciato a giocare io avevo due posti
di nascita nord di terraggio uno era in
mia città natale dei miei genitori della
mia famiglia Il secondo era
l'Italia
l'Italia precisamente Milano anni 80 ne
anni
80 in Italia Ho trovato la
gente che adorava la creatività adorava
l'entusiasmo adorava L'invenzione l'
adorava tutto quello che era legato a
qualcosa di
nuovo creativo Le porte si aprivano la
gente voleva comunicare a quel modo
eccetera quindi per quello che non
capisco che crisi c'è in Italia perché
qua in Italia la creatività è come
l'aria come
l'acqua e
poi tantissimi tempi fa ai tempi di
Leonardo Da Vinci non c'era l'internet
non c'era telefono mica treno aereo e
questo qua Faceva di tutto con la
famiglia medici inclusa
Però andiamo avanti il viaggio procede
qua è uno dei miei primi progetti di
abiti sculture che è un progetto molto
astratto però la prima realizzazione di
mio uno dei miei
sogni
e questo sono le scarpe sculture e
quello che vi sto facendo vedere sono
tutte le cose realizzate in Italia non
commerciali era solo tanto realizzare
sogno di
qualcuno senza pensare che domani
porterà 40 milioni di euro 50 milioni
cioè tutti quelli che hanno realizzato
Queste scarpe sono state realizzate da
Sergio
Rossi che poi quando ha visto disegno mi
ha detto guarda che noi siamo una seria
D che produce le
scarpe Cosè sta roba
qua F l'ha fatto ho fatto insieme E lì
ho incontrato per la prima volta i
laboratori sono abbastanza veloce sono
laboratori laboratori
che sono pieni di gente che ha voglia
che proprio ha la passione che ama
quello che fa e che poi non solo questo
ci stanno sul gioco e a parte fare le
scarpe normali
questa cosa qua si divertiva un sacco e
questo era punto di gioco e questo è il
forte di questo paese andiamo avanti eh
Questa è la seconda parte è nato il mio
figlio cioè ha atato il mio figlio e ha
portato un'altra valigia che io ho
dimenticato cioè quando si parte il
fretta fuia sempre si dimentica qualcosa
e col mio figlio sono arrivati Questi
personaggi prima 500 poi adesso sono
5600 personaggi e ogni mattina ogni
giorno sempre di
più questo è un
progetto che parte da una storia di una
città che
vola una
città questi sono pupa di questa città
sono tutte le realizzazioni
e questi sono primi giocattoli Scusate
era un po' veloce questi qua erano i
primi modelli che sono stati fatti da un
altro guardiano dei sognatori dei
bambini che si chiama Alberto Alessi che
è direttore artistico dell'alessi perché
io sono arrivato da lui con un paio di
disegni ha detto cosa neho chiesto cosa
ne pensi lui ha detto detto questo
potrebbero essere belli giocattoli e
così è partita la storia di giocattoli
questi sono solo degli esempi poi dopo
arrivo sul concetto questi sono
finalmente giocattoli realizzati con la
Moma di New York perché la Moma voleva
questi giocattoli io non gli volevo
perché non sapevo come
farlo però come loro volevano tanto G
abbiamo
realizzato
Ecco sono tutti insieme tutta la
famiglia componibili le tazze sempre
fatte in
Italia questo è sindaco della città di
Summer City che è un
semaforo che abita in un faro e città
vola e questo è il mio sindaco quello
che mi ha portato per la terra Comunque
andiamo avanti
ma
ok Questo è il taxi e questo della
Summer City che non ha il motore viaggia
solo per l'energia e questo è sindaco
che sta aspettando questa è unica cosa
italiana che poi mi
ha preso troppo è il vostro caffè perché
questo qua pure in Summer City nessuno
profumo Ma questo c'è il
cappuccino andiamo
avanti questa è la città con pesci di
oro e ogni pesce Puoi chiedere per tre
Come si chiamano wishes tre desideri
Questa è la Summer City Come si chiama
la mia città realizzata come un Show
teatrale che era molto bello adesso vi
sto parlando quando sto ritornando sul
discorso Quando sono diventato
bambino di professione ho cominciato a
cercare altri bambini adulti non solo
quelli
piccoli che vorrebbero esserci anche
parte del del mio progetto Allora questi
tutti attori nel teatro Per esempio
questo in arancio è un zucchina che
proprietario di un ristorante a New York
questo attore in un certo punto anche
fuori delle prove generali varie per
teatro ha cominciato a dire io sono
zucchina io sono sempre stato la
zucchina entrato completamente dentro
nel gioco anche questo è la sole sindaco
di città vikingo Tor che viaggia su una
nuvola però la storia è lunga andiamo
avanti per voglio Ecco questa è la saver
City Questo è il pensiero segreto che ha
ha inventato la sumer City
ed è un
progetto che avrà di scopo
di aprire quelle porte anche nei
adulti quello che noi abbiamo portato
come i bambini e quello che si quello
che si trova dentro di noi è quello che
non dobbiamo mai mai di
purtroppo in certi punti in tanti punti
abbiamo dimenticato abbastanza
Allora io con questo progetto vorrei
Questa è la Summer
City vorrei
far aiutare ai adulti di ritornare in
bambini di trovare i loro doni perché
noi tutti abbiamo sempre un 10 20 15 non
importa il numero dei doni magari
nessuno non ha avuto la fortuna
all'inizio che c'è qualcuno che gli apre
uno di questi canali dei doni del
bambini e più che altro a conservare
tutto questo e quindi io
direi Io vorrei con questo progetto che
un giorno Ah
ecco un giorno si inventa un Ministero
che legato solo ai bambini che è legato
solo alla questione dei
sogni la realizzazione dei
sogni e anche di spiegare quanto è
importante rimanere bambin bambino
Finché si è vivo perché tutto il
resto Ecco questi sono vari personaggi
della mia città sono di tutto il mondo
Ah ecco questa è la Musab
una mucca di
Barcellona è una fashion Fre ma è
molto a una scuola di danza personaggi
sono da per tutto il mondo e tutti sono
in disposizione di qualsiasi persona che
vuole
giocare Allora questa la us come il
pupaz sono tornato in Italia
quest'anno perché ho messo a punto un
progetto che si chiama Luna Art volevo
scoprire se in Italia c'è ancora
entusiasmo se ci sono ancora la gente
brava la gente che ha coraggio la gente
che vorrebbe realizzare qualcosa che non
hanno mai realizzato questi qua disegni
sono disegni dei abiti sculture che
saranno realizzati dalle aziende che non
hanno mai realizzato un Abit quindi era
un gioco
La storia è partita sempre con la
fabbrica Alessi che ha deciso di fare
tre abiti poi dopo abbiamo trovato altri
artigiani che volevano artisti artigiani
le produzioni che volevano realizzare
dei abiti Ecco qua sono Daniel papuli e
la sua
moglie moglie che hanno fatto degli
abiti di carta Guarda come sono contenti
perché hanno giocato
poi c sono Benedetta con la figlia con
loro abiti la Costanza che fa dei mobili
con loro Abiti sempre dal dal di qua del
Milano Lago d'Orta Ecco qua è Alessi
Questo è di Loli e Memoli che fanno dei
lampadari di
cristallo questo questa è una questi
sono della Artemide della lampada della
irinox che fa degli abbattitori per il
virus alcuni anche di
tessuta cosa è comune in questa cosa in
questa cosa è comune questo che tutta
questa gente è ritornata il
bambino
sono hanno avuto il
coraggio di ritornare i
bambini io personalmente ho trovato
questa grande voglia Eh perché voi
sapete quando eravate piccoli quando
giocavate qualche volta era bello
giocare da soli Però è sempre più bello
quando c'è tanta gente tanti amici a
giocare tutti insieme ogni uno portare
le loro i loro giocattoli le loro cose
eccetera allora A quel punto lì Io qua
ho trovato i bambini grandi che Italia è
piena con una grande voglia di
sperimentare grande voglia di inventare
grande voglia di
giocare quindi con questo mio progetto
voglio occuparvi e poi invito tutti
quelli che sono interessati a creare
questo grande mondo di
bambini perché questo è
essenziale se possiamo riuscire a
conservare questo bambino che c'è in noi
dal punto della nascita fino alla non
dico morte la partenza finale no
ecco
eh Penso che
tutto
[Musica]
Scusate
Grazie